якщо обертати кулю навколо однієї осі, а потім навколо іншої — це не те саме, що робити ці два оберти у зворотному порядку
сьогодні в Qiskit у класі ми побачимо, яке відношення ця куля має до квантових комп'ютерів і одного з найвідоміших
принципів квантової механіки — принципу невизначеності
ласкаво просимо до Qiskit у класі — відеосерії, де ми розбираємо фундаментальні концепції, з якими ти
можеш зустрітися в курсах, пов'язаних з квантовими обчисленнями. До кожного відео є інтерактивний модуль, посилання на який є в
описі нижче, тож обов'язково перевір його. Сьогодні ми говоримо про принцип невизначеності Гейзенберга. Якщо
ти вже чув про нього, то, мабуть, знаєш і старий жарт про Гейзенберга: одного дня його зупинили під час водіння, і поліцейський запитав його:
«Ви знаєте, з якою швидкістю їхали?» Гейзенберг відповів: «Ні, але я точно знаю, де я знаходжусь». Це, можна сказати,
принцип невизначеності Гейзенберга в двох словах: не можна одночасно знати положення та імпульс частинки
з ідеальною точністю. Це часто записують ось так: Delta x * Delta p більше або
дорівнює h / 2, де Delta X і Delta P — це
невизначеності положення та імпульсу, а H — мала фундаментальна константа в квантовій механіці
Гейзенберг вивів цю нерівність ще в 1927 році, коли думав про те, як виміряти положення електрона. Якщо
відбити від нього фотон, щоб дізнатися, де він перебуває, цей фотон неминуче вдарить електрон і порушить його
імпульс. Це не просто твердження про те, що вимірювання порушують систему — це говорить нам про те, що існують фундаментальні
обмеження на те, скільки ми можемо дізнатися про природу. Це один із прикладів більш загального принципу — додатковості, який
стверджує, що певні аспекти природи несумісні один з одним і не можуть спостерігатися
одночасно. Наприклад, квантові об'єкти іноді поводяться як частинки, а іноді як хвилі,
але спостерігати обидві поведінки одночасно неможливо. Зв'язок між положенням і імпульсом у Гейзенберга — це лише один із
багатьох наборів доповнюючих характеристик. Ця вроджена невизначеність пов'язана з тим, як ми розглядаємо такі властивості, як
положення та імпульс у квантовій механіці. Замість того щоб думати про X і P як про змінні чи внутрішні властивості,
якими кожна частинка наділена від природи, у квантовій механіці положення та імпульс — це оператори. Вони не є властивостями
системи, а тим, що можна зробити із системою. Щоб дізнатися про положення частинки, потрібно виконати
операцію над системою та здійснити вимірювання. Ця операція може вплинути на результат інших наступних
операцій. Як аналогія — уяви шматок сухого дерева. Воно має багато властивостей, таких як
положення, розмір, форма. Воно також має властивість горючості та здатності плавати у воді. Якби це дерево було
квантовим об'єктом, це не були б властивості, про які можна просто знати заздалегідь. Натомість ми кажемо, що це
спостережувані — речі, про які можна дізнатися, якщо виконати якусь операцію над системою. Тобто потрібно застосувати оператори
горючості або плавучості, що потребує насправді спробувати підпалити дерево або покласти його в
воду, щоб побачити, чи воно пливе. Тепер результат кожного з цих операторів залежить від порядку їх застосування. Якщо
спочатку перевірити горючість, дерево згорить на попіл і не можна буде перевірити, чи воно плаває. Але якщо перевірити
плавучість першою, то дерево буде надто мокрим, щоб горіти. Ми кажемо, що оператори горючості та
плавучості не комутують — порядок операцій має значення. Це призводить до фундаментального
обмеження на те, наскільки добре можна знати ці дві спостережувані характеристики шматка дерева, оскільки ми не можемо точно сказати, чи воно
горюче чи плавуче, не знаючи контексту цього вимірювання. Звичайно, зі справжнім шматком дерева ти
міг би розпиляти його навпіл і перевірити обидві властивості одночасно, але з квантовою частинкою нічого подібного зробити не можна. Ця
аналогія з деревом — це лише аналогія. Невизначеність є суто квантовим явищем. X і P також не комутують,
і ця властивість некомутативності і призводить до принципу невизначеності Гейзенберга. Загалом будь-які два оператори,
що не комутують, матимуть свій власний принцип невизначеності. Загальну форму принципу невизначеності можна
записати ось так: Delta a * Delta
B більше або дорівнює
1/2 від модуля очікуваного значення [a, b], де
ця дужка називається
комутатором, і це дорівнює різниці між застосуванням спочатку a, потім
B та застосуванням спочатку B, потім a. Ці кутові дужки
означають, що береться так зване очікуване значення того, що всередині. По суті, якщо робити одне й те саме
вимірювання багато-багато разів, очікуване значення — це середнє значення всіх цих вимірювань. Сьогодні ми
фактично перевіримо і підтвердимо цей принцип невизначеності на квантовому комп'ютері IBM. Ми розглянемо три різні
спостережувані qubit, покажемо, що їхні оператори не комутують, і в кінці зможемо довести, що
принцип невизначеності виконується для цих спостережуваних qubit. Але спочатку невеликий відступ про зручний спосіб візуалізувати квантовий
стан qubit. Його можна представити вектором, що вказує кудись на сферу, яка називається сферою Блоха. Я розповідав про це
в попередньому відео, посилання на яке є в описі, але тут теж коротко нагадаю. Ось
сфера Блоха. Кожен вектор параметризується двома кутами — Theta і F.
Стан нуль знаходиться на північному полюсі, стан один — на південному полюсі, а рівна суперпозиція 0 і 1 —
десь вздовж екватора, де f дорівнює відносній фазі між двома частинами
суперпозиції. Тож цей стан тут буде дорівнювати
1 / √2 |0⟩ + e^(i φ) |1⟩, де I — це
та фаза. Коли ми вимірюємо спостережувану qubit, результат завжди один із двох варіантів, що відповідають двом
можливим станам qubit. Для експерименту, який ми зараз проведемо, ми розглянемо три спостережувані та
відповідні їм оператори X, Y і Z. Коли вимірюєш будь-яку з цих спостережуваних, отримуєш або плюс один, або
мінус один з імовірністю, що залежить від кута між вектором qubit на сфері Блоха та
WEBVTT
віссю вимірювання. Як і можна було очікувати, Z вимірює вздовж осі Z, X — вздовж X,
а Y — вздовж Y. Пам'ятай, ми говоримо про спостережувані, тому що в квантовій
системі не можна просто знати речі про систему, не вимірюючи їх.
І кожна спостережувана має відповідну операцію, тому що вимірювання потребують операцій. Може бути не очевидним, але
виявляється, що операції — оператори, що відповідають кожній із цих спостережуваних x, y і z, — це
оберти на Pi навколо відповідних осей. Тобто X — це оберт навколо X, Y —
навколо Y, а Z — навколо Z. Щоб перевірити, чи комутують ці оператори, ми можемо перевірити, чи комутують оберти
на сфері. Якщо так — принцип невизначеності не застосовується, і ми змогли б знати X, Y і Z qubit
з ідеальною точністю. Якщо ні — ми зможемо знайти нове співвідношення невизначеності для qubit. Стеж
за точкою на цій кулі, поки я оберту спочатку навколо X, а потім навколо Y. Вона опиняється
тут. Тепер спробуємо у зворотному порядку: оберту спочатку навколо Y, а
потім навколо X. Вона опиняється ось тут. Тож вони точно не комутують. Це означає,
що ми не можемо одночасно знати точні значення X, Y і Z qubit — матимемо
співвідношення невизначеності. Ми пропустимо деталі тут, але в підсумку отримаємо три різних співвідношення
невизначеності. Тобто Delta x * Delta Y
більше або дорівнює Z, Delta y * Delta Z більше або
дорівнює X, і Delta Z * Delta X більше або дорівнює
Y. Тобто добуток будь-яких двох невизначеностей завжди більший або
дорівнює очікуваному значенню третьої спостережуваної. Давай скористаємося Qiskit, щоб подивитися, що
відбувається, коли ми намагаємося виміряти і Z, і X для стану нуль. Виміряти Z легко — це так звана стандартна база
квантового комп'ютера, вимірювання за замовчуванням завжди вздовж Z. Але щоб виміряти X, потрібно виконати так звану
зміну базису — по суті, повернути сферу Блоха так, щоб X тепер вказував вгору там, де раніше вказував Z. Для цього
ми використовуємо Hadamard gate. Тож повний quantum circuit виглядатиме так: вимірюємо в Z, застосовуємо Hadamard
і потім вимірюємо в X. Якщо використати Qiskit Primitive Sampler, щоб запустити цей експеримент багато разів, ми отримаємо
гістограму результатів вимірювань, яка виглядає ось так для вимірювання в Z
і ось так для вимірювання в X. Як бачиш, ми виміряли
qubit у стані нуль вздовж Z майже зі 100% впевненістю, але
вздовж X ми практично нічого не знали про стан qubit: він вимірювався як нуль або один з однаковою
імовірністю, тобто наша невизначеність в X була максимальною. Це дає нам
певне відчуття цього компромісу між невизначеностями, але на квантовому комп'ютері можна зробити трохи краще. Ми можемо використати
Qiskit Primitive під назвою Estimator, щоб знайти очікувані значення наших спостережуваних X, Y і Z і
невизначеність у кожній. Спробуємо для стану, що вказує в напрямку плюс X на сфері Блоха. Використаємо Estimator,
щоб обчислити невизначеності в x і z для цього стану та очікуване значення
y. Для цього стану ми отримуємо такий результат від Qiskit. Коли беремо добуток двох
невизначеностей в X і Y, то бачимо, що, як і очікувалося, він більший за абсолютне
значення очікуваного значення y. Але це було лише для одного конкретного стану — хочемо переконатися, що ця нерівність
виконується для всіх станів qubit. Тож знову використаємо Estimator, але цього разу попросимо його пройтися по значеннях
параметра і знайти очікувані значення при кожному значенні параметра. Параметр, по якому хочемо
пройтися, — це кут Theta на сфері Блоха, щоб перевірити нерівність для всіх станів qubit, що лежать на
цій дузі, яка перетинає площину XZ. Коли ми це робимо, отримуємо графік як функцію кута Theta. Червона
крива — це добуток двох невизначеностей, а помаранчева — очікуване значення y. Як і очікувалося,
добуток невизначеностей в x і z набагато більший за очікуване значення y. Але нерівність
не надто складно виконати, тому що очікуване значення y було дуже низьким — воно дорівнювало нулю для всіх станів на
цій дузі. Зробимо схожий прохід по значеннях Theta, але замість площини XZ встановимо φ рівним pi/
4 — тобто розглядаємо стани qubit, що лежать на іншій дузі на сфері. Тут бачимо, що нерівність перевіряється
трохи жорсткіше, оскільки помаранчева та червона криві розташовані ближче одна до одної, але червона завжди вище за помаранчеву,
і принцип невизначеності все одно виконується. Ми ще не перевірили всі стани, але, мабуть, ти вже починаєш розуміти
суть. Існує фундаментальна непізнаваність будь-яких двох доповнюючих аспектів квантової
системи, включно з цим qubit. Принцип невизначеності змушує нас визнати факт, що як би ми не намагалися,
як би розумними не були наші вимірювання, ми ніколи не знатимемо все з ідеальною точністю.
Від цього нікуди не дітися. Якщо не віриш мені — або навіть якщо й віриш — кидаю тобі виклик: перевір модуль,
посилання на який є в описі, і спробуй перемогти принцип невизначеності. Дякую за перегляд, до наступного разу!